però se ne yo fra tutti gli altri li ho
riconosciuti son rose rose parlano
d'amore
penso che un sogno così non ritorni mai
più
vi dipingevo le mani e la faccia di
[Musica]
poi d'improvviso venivo dal vento rapito
e incomincio a volare nel cielo infinito
con 24 mila baci oggi saprei perché
l'amore per ogni santa mille baci mille
carezzevole allora mille bolle blu blu
bene intorno anche bruno mille mollato e
morano
dimmi quando tu verrà
dimmi quando quando quando
l'anno il giorno all'ora in cui
forte tu mi piace ai ciao amore ciao
ciao
ora c'è
grande questa mano
6 mar
timi pure che destino
tra dio non vedo più
rosa
non credo
no no
la differenza fra più cieco ma era più
stupida pazienza sentinella
c'è già
ragazzo
ore che no
come un pensiero che sa bene
siccità
lasciatevi canta
con la chitarra in mano
no no
lasciatemi cantare
sono un italiano voglio una vita e
maleducata di quelle ride fate così
voglio una vita chissenefrega che se ne
frega di tutto se
voglio una vita che non è mai tardi
di quelle che non darmi ma
voglio una vita vedrai che edita vedrà
e ci sei
e adesso a dare un senso ai giorni miei
va tutto bene dal momento che ci sei
è difficile spiegare certe giornate a
mare lascia stare tanto ci potrà
ritrovare
tu che sei
viva
corso
almeno tu
con me
non mi verso un punto 6 che norma
madama
che splende per me soltanto come un
diamante
penso al cuore
non amarmi perché vivo all'ombra non
amarmi per
cambiare il mondo tanto
non si cambia siamo tutti specchi fatti
bene
amarsi e diventare solo
e vecchi chissà se tu mi pensi
se con i tuoi non parli mai se ti nasco
a chi come me sfuggire i sguardi e te ne
stai rinchiuso anche a me
vuoi mangiare e stringe forte a te
cuscino e biaggi e non lo sai
quant'altro male
come ti farà a solitudine come saprei
[Musica]
guardi dio
lo sa
a breve ma
come saprete
ehi riuscirci io ancora non lo sa
a
la cambio io la
vita che e mi ha deluso dite
portami al mare
fammi sognare
dimmi che non vuoi
siamo nella stessa logica
come un sole è una stella
siamo in luce che cade giochi
[Applauso]
suoi tramonti della mia terra
a giorni
non c'è
prenditi cura di lei
lei
lei non sa vedere al di là
ma lì quello che tu pensa prima di
sparare e pensa prima di dire di
giudicare prova a pensare
pensa che puoi decidere
no questo no
no non è l'inferno
ma non comprendo
o
chrome è possibile pensare che sia più
facile morire mentre il mondo cade a
pezzi
io compongo nuovi spazi e desideri
che
appartengono anche a te che era sempre
sei per me
l'essenziale
temi che sai che solo le scegliere
[Musica]
ora lo sa
tu sei unico grande amore
lezioni di nirvana c'è il buddha in fila
indiana
per tutti un'ora d'aria di gloria la
folla grida un mantra l'evoluzione
inciampa la scimmia nuda palla
occidentali scar ma a me
no tu rimani fuori dal mio diario degli
errori da tutte le mie contraddizioni da
tutti i torti e le ragioni non mi avete
fatto niente non avete avuto miei
niente
perché tutto va oltre le vostre inutili
guerre
sdraiato a terra come i doors
vestito bene michael kors
perdo la testa come chiedi a 27 come
rosa è difficile stare al mondo
quando perdi l'orgoglio nasci casa in un
giorno tu dimmi se pensa visto un iphone
di soldi come se avessi avuto soldi
soldi
[Musica]
fa male di te vada
adesso ma non so più cosa c'è
tanto c'è solamente di inventarsi delle
nuove parole potrei dirti che
siamo soltanto vaga
all viaggiamo in ordine sparso
si è solamente di inventarsi e delle
nuove parole
come potrei scrivere per le nuove
canzoni d'amore e cantar del e qui
perché sanremo è sanremo